it's Monday I'm back but unfortunately
now just a sec thanks no worries but for
all of you guys I've got something to
star for gamespot years I'm wearing a
coat because I'm cold also there's a
console coming from a company probably
wouldn't expect that's right Atari
released images of their first console
in over 20 years and here it is the
Atari box Oh fancy
the console will come in two flavors the
red and black current version you're
staring at right now and a classic black
with wood paneling design a throwback to
the Atari 2600 in a letter to fans
published by Kotaku Atari said they're
aiming to appeal to both old and new
fans alike and the console will feature
an array of modern ports including HDMI
USB and an SD card slot they went on to
say that while the Atari box will
deliver classic gaming content the
company will also be delivering current
gaming content so make of that what you
will
the Atari box was first teased in June
and Atari have said that there will be
lots more information and status updates
to come as development progresses after
finally revealing the Kingdom Hearts 3
is coming in 2018 game director Tetsuya
Nomura has said why the game took so
long to make fans have been waiting
since 2005 for another Kingdom Hearts
game to come out and they're finally
getting their wish as for what's
happened in the meantime Nomura
explained a lot of people have been
mentioning and making it sound like oh
no more is taking too much time and that
hurts there was a decision made to
change to an external engine Unreal
Engine 4 unfortunately there was a bit
of time that needed to be rewinded and
started over so there was a bit of a
setback there but it was a decision that
the company had to make so it was
inevitable Nomura added that internal
personnel was limited for the manpower
they needed to create content in a
timely manner
so they had to wait he made a point to
note that there is not been an issue
with the development teams to cause a
delay in development you can check out
the full Toy Story worlds gameplay
trailer which debuted at d23 on GameSpot
Nomura has said more worlds will be
shown off leading up to launch Bungie
have discussed how Call of Duty
influenced the design of a mission in
death
in the latest edition of the Bungie
podcast designer Rob and Gayle spoke
about the development of the black
spindle mission in the first destiny for
those who don't know what that is the
black spindle mission was an ultimate
pathway that had to be unlocked in an
existing mission which then requires
players to kill everything that appears
within a 10 minute time limit successful
Guardians were then rewarded with the
black spindle sniper rifle obviously
neither of us ever got it interestingly
and gals spoke about how the mile-high
club mission in call of duty 4 modern
warfare
influenced the design of the Destiny
mission along with his own appreciation
of difficult obstacles that require a
high level of familiarity and mastery to
complete in mile-high club players have
to rescue a hostage on a plane in a set
time limit after watching speedruns of
the mission and Galan said what I liked
about that was the constant sense of
mastery where you could see them
anticipating exactly where every enemy
would be they had a script basically
that they were following elsewhere in
the podcast and Gil spoke about how
destiny carry culture the practice of
high-level play is helping lower level
players through the game's most
difficult content influenced destiny -
he said that's something that's really
valuable to us and when we were talking
about what do we want the virtual game
in destiny to to look like preserving
that carry culture was one of the things
that game director Luke Smith told me
mattered most to him the destiny to beta
kicks up tomorrow July 18 on ps4 and
July 19 on Xbox one for those that have
pre-ordered and for everyone else on
July 21 a PC beta will be out sometime
in late August that's it for GameSpot
news for today hopefully I've infected
you with at least a little bit of
knowledge unfortunately I've infected
Jessica with some kind of culture she's
going to go home now but I will see you
tomorrow will she be here will she not
journey tomorrow to find out